what's the most random place you've done
a show at random
csb chasing was gangstered in a [ __ ]
sheilsby man seals be taste as [ __ ]
gangster I ain't gonna lie [ __ ] on a
one-way Street
one way the street by probably the size
of this table seemed like
you can only go one way this [ __ ] was
packed I know like the building was so
[ __ ] it was it was it was big in the
inside but it was like real small though
it seemed like type [ __ ] but the street
was smaller [ __ ] long story short
we I'm performing on the stage with my
burner with my pistol in my hand and in
Texas that's okay yeah but it's not
normal just for [ __ ] just before
doing a rap song while holding this
there was so many [ __ ] behind us with
guns out that was like just some
gangster [ __ ] like I swear to God like
them [ __ ] is Gangster I [ __ ] with that
[ __ ] so you performed holding your gun
gun in my hand my uncle them and
everybody else behind me hit they straps
out [ __ ] behind us who we didn't even
know hit they guns out so I'm knowing I
ain't no telling how many [ __ ] in
front of us got straps and [ __ ] then we
get up after mud it took us about like
an hour to get up out there [ __ ]
it was just so smile like everybody
where in Texas is this it's by like by
Beaumont it's right beside Beaumont
beaumont's near Houston right right yeah
so or something like that right yeah
yeah some [ __ ] like that so
[Music]
they supposed got some type of beef I
guess Jesus I don't know but I just know
we're using that [ __ ] it took a
long time to get out there [ __ ]
we finally when we literally hit the
street and made it right cause we hit
like it was like in the neighborhood
residential area type [ __ ] they just had
a place
[Music]
like where they live just sitting in
like in the front yard and everything
just posted sitting on their cars and
everything so we see [ __ ] I'm talking
about they got big old glass Choppers
and [ __ ] like we looking at the [ __ ]
with this home like man what the [ __ ]
like what the [ __ ] is we doing like like
these [ __ ] gangster than a [ __ ] soon
as we turned out the street
Jesus
that's crazy they start letting them
[ __ ] go not at us they had some
more beef going on but at least you got
him out of there yeah see everybody with
Gangster than a [ __ ]